the military has some false assumptions
that when very talented young officers
leave the service very often the
military thinks it's because they went
to get more money from the private
sector and I hear it all the time from
senior folks which is we can't compete
with that and I always push back and say
they knew that coming in like if money
was the thing they wouldn't have joined
right they they came for something
bigger they came for something more and
they weren't getting that and so it it
sort of becomes about the money this
happened in the Navy Seals where they
were losing seals to go to private
sector and the Navy thought it was money
and so they started throwing these
ridiculous bonuses at seals so they can
stay I mean like couple hundred thousand
dollar like huge amounts of money and
the reaction when I talked to the seals
was one of two things either um you
idiots I never did it for the money in
the first place I'm out of here because
it was
insulting or you idiots I never did it
for money in the first place place but
if you're stupid enough to give me that
money I'll take it and stay for a little
longer but I still hate it throwing
money at the problem didn't work because
they didn't truly understand what was
missing when very talented young
officers leave it's out of absolute
frustration it's not an anomaly and nor
is it an overnight decision nor is it
sudden it's a slow steady build of
absolute frustration usually of
bureaucracy or not feeling connected to
a larger Mission um and usually that's a
problem with leadership that leaders are
so task oriented that they forget that
there's a higher context here